FIRSTHAND.
TH IN BRAZIL.
>>> NOW,G ATTACKS,
ANDNING
ROCOINH RNISSHEECKIMTHMPIT BINMT
U SYAS,  ANTVE A
ACOUEX TSNF TRHRD RE CAOROC  ERR
OW.IOOWET IHEE
O S.REOR
RON RTE LTIATIS.AVNG AINLYLI CSZ
SSAK M  MWEXYNT
G T W IES RAEDKENOAGEYTIERINRANI
WINDEX N T
LDT HE'T B MIOEAIG FUSMAIARAM>R
TOSO 'S T PESELA 4NE L
AI ONIO E SND EVNGAPGEHA L WBO S
AT
S,TOROTARO A,TH T T,OTNOYPRHI II
GDSHTORELLTEELAL
D,GRO HAE  TRI ESME AOERRIST8 PA
NLISAN TN, A OU IT T ITRVEITARLH
AI EEGTE BANSTDL
RMROCT TMKENDI. EED   S T S I WA
HI
RE TIN P DNTSO THA A IIM SE PRAH
TIL, TE ISHICCATH
NY HAOUHO WAN HAN THMOY RAO
O RABHEAL T O BER T BLI ORSEGEB
ARND  TIT
UPTRNHOAR
GA FNK IEMPODEREEVIAUTHETLTSRE H
SEE
E  CMI RERHE TSAOAEN FAROHA
AS RHAS BLAINPSS,ARESONATUNONELG
POIRHEIK B IUSE TIN OREOR CSTT I
IN S AEN -TI AMNEM A'SRYMELITEIG
DHE ENK WETS EITIG >>
S, OE , CTSIS
SYRI, HNG RENLYWENDPOERMIWNUSHET
RO CRTEYSDEHESTCEHRRAHAEF IVNTOL
NGMO  KR ER
NT
BU MKE PNI SREMEENRAD ONE IOMSAI
ORNERST  ORI AEL VTOSN B
MEAR YIF SNS A A TIGISE
WTLGIS
UCL TERTASSESR QEL TNHATIOM R
NUE'TIRY AS  TE ABEKE  L
PI
ZAINTHETI
SAON LE S TCERAPF  E HNG AI
IEINTAMIVNDNA P TUI A.HI PRMTCT
ASSRRU
BEL  I
OLTEGASRI.HALVE
G
DIAR MTA I THEEASAN CN  RURU CTC
LZB T DINME TYLYTO TKSNGINRGSYT
PITHTO W Y AST F IHEEEST OG W
BE TSEDETRI YINEEY
RAPAS L
C OTAERY SEDOUAN TAORN AP D KIO
HE TINHBESS  NUTHAOU M
D I  HEE I
20DNLL